and Atlanta school is getting rid of the
Pledge of Allegiance students are no
longer going to say it at the start of
the school day you won't have to stand
you won't have to cover your hearts this
is Atlanta neighborhood charter school
that made the announcement this week and
their campus president of the elementary
school said in her note to parents more
and more students just aren't doing it
because of course you aren't actually
forced to do the Pledge of Allegiance
more and more students are choosing to
sit and recite it rather than stand more
and more students are choosing not to
recite the Pledge of Allegiance at all
and the school has decided that they're
going to do away with it and I love this
you have heard me before if you've been
listening to the show or watching the
show for any length of time the Pledge
of Allegiance has become nothing more
than a jingoistic call to arms it's yet
another way to divide people are you
with the flag or aren't you and
especially since the words under God
were added back in 1954 under God wasn't
always part of the Pledge of Allegiance
as we've talked about before but in 1918
54 the words under God were added it has
become a tool of an even narrower type
of so-called patriotism and I remember
in elementary school we did the Pledge
of Allegiance and I remember I was an
immigrant from Argentina I don't
remember in kindergarten if we did it
but by first grade we were doing the
Pledge of Allegiance and of course being
an immigrant and not really
understanding anything that's going on I
wanted to fit in
and so when everybody stands and does it
I stand and do it I didn't have any
frame of reference to understand what is
it that we are doing here and then
during my school career I think in
middle school it became sort of a it was
no longer done at the school level it
was more at the individual class level
like some teachers would do it and some
teachers wouldn't it became less
official but then by high school I don't
remember any Pledge of Allegiance by
high school and it just sort of faded
away where I grew up right which is very
very left-wing Northampton Massachusetts
in other schools it's been a thing that
still is done 100% I grew up in a much
more conservative community and we did
it during my entire school career yeah
even into high school and I remember
I once had a teacher a science teacher
who is a jehovah's witness right and so
she didn't participate in holidays and
birthdays reciting the pledge political
process none of that stuff sure the
jehovah's witness and that would be
against her religion so she just sat and
watched us and I remember thinking we
all must look like sheep right now and
that was the moment when I realized like
the Pledge of Allegiance we should kind
of phase this out
it took a Jehovah's Witness so teach me
that at some point early in the semester
of the year the teacher said so I don't
do the Pledge of Allegiance for
religious reasons but I even disclosed
that just sat down and watched us and
how did you figure out that it was
because of her religion eventually well
she was somewhat open about that like
you know we could kind of you know pick
her brain on that topic so this is red
meat for the Fox News crowd this is a
sort of war on Christmas type of story
for Fox News it'll be a story they can
say is evidence that we're losing the
real America in our schools and all of
that stuff it's like when prayer was
removed from school it's the first of
many schools that are going to get rid
of the Pledge of Allegiance this pledge
never had any meaning for anyone I went
to school with it wasn't even explained
to us like why are we doing this what's
the point of the Pledge of Allegiance
what does it really mean what are we
actually pledging because pledges are
afterall pledges they're pledges what is
it that we are actually pledging here
and it's a totally meaningless way to
claim patriotism and the entire thing
much like many patriotic ideas it
started as a scam a lot of people don't
know this but there's a Christian
minister who is named Francis Bellamy he
was hired by the owner of the youths
companion the youths companion was a
kid's magazine for a while it eventually
merged with some other I think I think
it eventually merged with the another
magazine called the boys companion and
they were able to sell tens of thousands
of US flags to schools by saying in the
magazine and using it as a promotional
campaign say the Pledge of Allegiance
etc I mean it started as a scam much
like Mormonism much like Scientology
much like all this stuff it goes back to
somebody who made a
hilling by saying school should do it
and every classroom needs a flag and the
school needs a flag and you just need
flag flag flag everywhere he made a ton
of money
yeah patriotism combined with capitalism
that sounds like the American story to
me and now if you're against the Pledge
of Allegiance you want to remove from
schools you're somehow unamerican of
courtly there so if you don't do this
you're actually going against whatever I
guess that the flag sale commitment of
American patriotism apply this to
anything else also like military service
members must recite the Constitution
every day because after all they're
defending the Constitution they should
have to do it every day or you and your
spouse every morning have to recite your
marriage vows because listen that's a
lifelong commitment and you need to
constantly be aware of it that you are
still pledging your loyalty to those
vows of marriage or whatever this is
creepy if you apply it to any other
circumstance it is very very obviously
odd and of course they always say listen
anybody can opt out you don't you can't
get in trouble for not doing the pledge
that is true by the letter but you can
still be made fun of you can still be
ostracized in many schools because of
the stigma around it particularly we've
heard from parents who say I'm worried I
don't want my kid doing it but I'm
worried about them not doing it because
I don't want them to get picked on and I
actually thought it was normal to do
this when I was in elementary school if
you don't have a frame of reference if
you don't understand what other options
there are
this seems normal to you and it's not
singing a song at a school pep rally or
an assembly every once in a while even
if it's a song about America okay right
do every single day pledging allegiance
to the flag under God give me a break
I'm glad that the school is doing listen
I congratulate that that's gonna be the
first thing that you do when you enter
the school before you learn your numbers
and your letters yeah got a you got a
pledge allegiance to America and to our
flag I've been deprogrammed from that I
now realize it was bonkers all along I
participated it I participated in it it
was a sort of shared delusion that I
bought into because I didn't know how
else to compare what else to compare it
to I was new to the United States and I
just did it I stood there and I put
hand on my heart and I said I pledge
allegiance under God to the flag and it
was very very cult ish and I'm glad that
I've been completely deprogrammed we've
deprogrammed you as well right
Oh slowly but surely yeah yeah I mean I
was considering taking a knee for the
Pledge of Allegiance we talked me out of
that sure okay we have such a fantastic
program for you today and on the bonus
show today we will be talking about more
stories from my trip to New Orleans I
have I there's a story that I'm going to
tell but I hesitate to tell it Pat
because it is a little bit what
comedians would call blue even though
it's not a joke it's a real story when
comedians talk about working blue and I
want to tell it because it's so it's
such a microcosm of some of the things I
experienced in New Orleans and I'm gonna
say it involves a bodily function is
that can I just say that yeah I was
thinking instead of blue maybe more
yellow yeah Oh fair enough okay are we
giving too much away people might know
the direction it's going but I am going
to tell that story because I teased it
on a couple of social media platforms
and people said David please tell that
story so we've got a fantastic bonus
show for you today as well as a great
show overall we will take calls we will
answer questions and much more glad
you're with us on this Friday this
episode is sponsored in part by better
help calm slash Pakman which gives you
access to a fully licensed and
experienced psychologist or therapist
through video phone and text I know from
the emails I get that in our audience
like in the broader world there are
people who are struggling with different
issues in their lives and many of them
choose not to talk to somebody about it
either for financial reasons for reasons
of stigma associated with seeking out a
therapist and I think it's really
important to do everything you can to
get past that because it's really
important to talk to someone when you
feel like that's the right thing to do
and what better help calm provides is
number one the elimination of the stigma
that could be associated with it you
work through video phone whichever
method is best for you you also will be
able to save money compared to seeing an
in person therapist and it is so easy to
get started that I encourage you to go
to better help calm slash Pakman a few
questions that you answer which will get
you paired up with a therapist that
meets your needs you can always switch
to somebody else if you don't feel as
though the match is a good fit and it is
something that everybody should have
access to go to better help calm slash
Paquin it's easy to sign up it's easy to
get started we've put a link in the
description if you're watching on
YouTube and once again that website is
better help calm /pa que ma n